Donald Trump is getting indicted on 37
counts and he is facing a hypothetical
536 years in prison and some of his
lawyers have quit I am now going to
catch you up on what is going on with
Donald Trump we had some of the
information last week we now have more
Trump charged with 37 counts in
classified documents case indictment
says among other allegations the
indictment says Trump showed classified
documents to other people in the summer
of 2021 after leaving office the
indictment was made public a day after
the grand jury charged Trump two of
Trump's lawyers resigned from
representing him in the classified
documents case and in another pending
Federal criminal investigation into his
efforts to overturn the loss in 2020.
mediaite reporting Trump maximum
sentences add up to a staggering 536
years in prison for all counts I tell
you this not to trick you into thinking
Trump might end up spending this much
time in in prison or any time in prison
at all I still believe the most likely
outcome at greater than 50 odds is that
Trump will spend no time in prison I
tell you this to tell you the severity
of the totality of what Donald Trump has
been charged with so I want to talk
about a few different things here I'm
not going to do a deep dive legal
analysis because I'm not a lawyer and
there are many lawyers who can do the
Deep dive legal analysis I'm going to
give you an analysis of the politics
that is surrounding what is going on
here number one there are so many of you
who have written to me and have said
David sir some less politely but many of
you uh referring to me as Sir saying um
this is it right the trumpists now are
going to abandon Trump and the answer is
absolutely not Luke Luke the bee's knees
Beasley is going to be on the ground for
us tomorrow in Miami interviewing Trump
supporters and you are going to see not
only are they not abandoning Trump they
are flocking to his defense the one
remaining analysis that is valid for
what we are now seeing the defenses of
trump from the magicalists is the cult
analysis three books which I recommended
on my live stream over the weekend if
you want to understand what is going on
with trumpists are three books by the
great non-fiction author Jeff Gwen Jeff
Quinn wrote a book about Charles Manson
the leader of the family uh who died in
prison some years ago uh he wrote a Jeff
Gwynn wrote a book about Jim Jones The
Cult leader of the people's Temple the
that was the
murder suicide involving the quote
Kool-Aid that so many people have heard
of and then David koresh of the Branch
Davidians in Waco his most recent book
is about that it is impossible as I
recently read Waco and have previously
read the other books it is impossible to
read those books and not see trumpism in
the descriptions of the cultists and the
cult loyalty that we see or we saw to
koresh Jones and Manson that is the most
important analysis as far as what we are
seeing from the Trump supporters so then
let's continue
um you are going to hear
defenses of trump from cultists but also
from Republican uh hacks who do this for
a living you are going to hear all sorts
of claims about how this isn't really
that serious and there's really nothing
here and what about Hillary and what
about Hunter Etc the Brazen nature of
that which Trump is accused of credibly
we see evidence in the indictment Trump
not cooperating on the classified
documents moving documents around
seemingly to evade law enforcement
spending months refusing to turn
documents over we found that the
surveillance room
uh was flooded by a Mar-A-Lago employee
when they drained a pool into the
surveillance room although they say that
was not deliberate but it is
extraordinarily suspicious retention of
classified documents showing people
classified documents who don't have
proper security clearances Trump has
lied about every aspect of this he said
oh I Declassified everything
telepathically or whatever but there are
recordings of trump saying I can't show
you these documents because they're
classified meaning he knew that he
didn't actually declassify them so there
are many charges under the Espionage
Etc and we will leave it to the legal
experts to give you the bottom line on
that you can make the argument and I
would defend the argument that we have a
problem in the United States with over
classification of documents we've talked
about it before that's not an argument
I'm afraid of but we're talking about
very serious stuff right here documents
related to military capabilities weapons
capabilities about the Us and other
countries it if Obama had done this they
would be saying it's treason and it
should be the death penalty do not be
confused for even a moment we don't know
what Trump's motive was we just don't
know at this time why was he keeping
these documents one of the things we do
know based on the pictures that have
been released is that Donald Trump was
keeping these documents in boxes in his
bathroom by the way the bad is I've told
you before money can't buy class
um Trump's bathroom for a rich guy is
just it's all it's all crazy okay it's
every detail of this is insane but he
had documents in the bathroom he had
documents in his bedroom it's all
completely whacked another defense that
you're hearing is that these are
technical crimes process crimes Trump
hasn't been given due process but the
very same people saying that were
demanding Hillary Clinton be jailed
absent any evidence of criminality
absent an indictment absent an
adjudication a conviction and a
sentencing they were saying just Do not
pass go do not collect two hundred
dollars go straight to prison the very
same people saying I'm for Law and Order
were saying that or said lock up Joe
Biden or whatever and you've got
pictures of Trump's bathroom stuffed
with boxes we have recorded
conversations they want Hunter Biden
jailed and yet we have nothing on Hunter
Biden that is even close to what this
indictment reveals they have on Trump so
you're going to see those people
uh and those very same people making
these defenses might show up tomorrow to
Riot outside the Miami Courthouse I hope
that that doesn't happen but Trump and
others have been uh
inside you know I guess there's really
no other word other than they've been
inciting individuals to go to Miami
tomorrow we saw Mark Levin's delusional
rant on Fox News saying how how dare
they indignant how their how dare they
do this to Trump and it's really
important to remember that not only are
these serious charges and not only do
they seem to have Trump dead to rights
pictures audio recordings all of it one
of the other important things to think
about when it comes to this situation uh
is that this actually shows us we might
have accountability in a justice system
that does have two tiers the two tiers
aren't Democrats and Republicans
Republicans are now saying this it's a
two-tier justice system where if you're
a trump supporter there's different
rules no the two-tier justice system
we've had in this country for a long
time is everybody else and then the
wealthy and the elite who get the best
most expensive lawyers they uh don't
have pre-trial detention either because
it's not assigned or because they can
bail out or whatever that the two-tier
justice system has been that
and what we are to take away from Trump
getting indicted is that no one is above
the law Trump and others keep saying if
they can do this to me they're going to
do it to you
they're already doing it to the
proverbial you we know that the question
was can even someone in a position like
president be held accountable and at
least as far as the indictment goes the
answer might be yes we're going to talk
about Judge Eileen Cannon after the
break and that's going to concern Us in
in some ways last thing and I talked
about this on my stream you might be
wondering am I going to demand Trump's
imprisonment for life or something you
you might notice that in in the story so
far I haven't said Trump should be in
prison or Trump should be in prison for
X Y or Z amount of time because that's
not due process all I want is due
process okay we had enough evidence to
go to a grand jury the grand jury said
that said there is enough evidence to
indict so we've gotten an indictment so
I'm not around here saying oh imprison
Trump for Life what I want is now that
there has been an indictment let's
adjudicate it and depending on its
adjudication either via a plea deal or a
guilty plea a guilty verdict rather then
we can figure out what would be
appropriate sentencing and then let's
talk about a sentence I actually support
law and order I actually support due
process I'm not going around demanding
people be imprisoned because I don't
like their politics I don't like Trump's
politics but what I want
is the same thing that I want for Hunter
Biden if you believe he committed crimes
for Hillary Clinton or whatever the case
may be later in the program we will talk
about the difference between the Trump
classified documents indictment and what
they wanted Hillary locked up for and if
you come with an open mind I can only
imagine you will come away realizing
there is almost no comparison between
the two make sure you're subscribed to
the YouTube channel at youtube.com the
davidpackman show it is a massive
program today long and wide that I can
assure you if you've been getting
crushed in the markets lately like many
people have you were probably happy to
hear that treasury yields have been
surging right now you can get a five
percent yield on treasury bills Which is
higher than most high-yield savings
accounts I've seen and unlike a
high-yield savings account treasury
bills are a fixed rate asset so you know
what you're getting at the time of
purchase but buying U.S treasuries can
be very complicated or at least it was
because our sponsorpublic.com lets you
buy treasury bills in seconds right from
your phone and put your cash to work
keep in mind that treasury bills are
government-backed securities considered
one of the safest Investments around
when you buy them on public they are
securely stored at the Bank of New York
Mellon the world's largest custodian
bank and Security Services Company plus
there are no minimum hold periods or
settlement delays you can access funds
anytime if you keep it invested public
will automatically roll over your
Investments at maturity so you have one
thing you don't have to think about go
to public.com Pacman to start getting
that five percent yield on your cash the
link is down below